pero no me ven france24 me acompaña el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida del gobierno de cuba
renunciara a la participación
mayoritaria en las empresas mixtas
raúl buenas noches del primero le cuento
que en la década del 90 cuba autorizó a
las compañías mixtas es decir que tenga
participación privada y pública pero con
la condición de tener una porción
estatal mayoritaria el ministro de
comercio e inversión extranjera rodrigo
malmierca reveló que esa exigencia se va
a eliminar para proyectos de turismo
biotecnología y comercio mayorista lo
que podría fomentar la inversión en
estos sectores pero en los que si se va
a mantener es en los sectores de
extracción de recursos naturales y
prestación de servicios públicos
danielle en otras noticias mientras
reino unido- se aleja poco a poco de la
unión europea se acerca a eeuu
bueno no había mucho que esperar de la
cena entre boris johnson y ursula von
der leyen pues ambos quedaron en que los
diálogos continúan y esperan tener una
decisión pronto lo que sí es seguro es
que
mientras se aleja de este conjunto de
países londres trata de estrechar lazos
con otros y el primero es su lista de
deseos es eeuu el departamento de
comercio anunció que suspenderá
unilateralmente los aranceles que se le
han impuesto como parte de la larga
disputa comercial por los subsidios
aéreos pues uno de los perjudicados ha
sido el whisky escocés el objetivo es de
reducir la escalada del conflicto y
llegar a un acuerdo negociado para
profundizar sus relaciones pero también
hay otros beneficiados
hace poco reino unido- firmó un acuerdo
comercial con japón y hoy concluyeron
las conversaciones para hacerlo con
vietnam al tiempo firmó con canadá una
extensión de los acuerdos ya vigentes
daniela ahora explíquenos por favor un
poco que significa que el gobierno de
méxico no va a suprimir la
subcontratación laboral
raúl miren esa fue la promesa que le
hizo el ejecutivo en un acuerdo con
empresarios y sindicatos firmado hoy y
les cuento hace varias semanas estalló
una polémica porque el presidente dijo
que iba a eliminar la tercerización
laboral también conocida como
porque dice que abusa de los derechos de
los trabajadores ahora dice que lo que
vas a regularla en lugar de suprimirla
los empresarios han coincidido en que
esa forma de contratación es legal
aunque muchos hagan mal uso de ella
los banqueros aplaudieron los anuncios
pero no lo hicieron igual los gremios
como el consejo nacional agropecuario o
la confederación patronal que en su
cuenta de 'twitter' insistió en que el
gobierno pretende coartar la libertad de
la subcontratación y atentar contra la
creación de empleos formales y en otras
noticias facebook enfrenta una doble
lucha antimonopolio en eeuu aún son dos
demandas presentadas al tiempo una de la
comisión federal de comercio y otra de
48 estados y distritos y ambas se basan
en lo mismo que facebook supuestamente
ha abusado de su poder para aplastar a
sus competidores más pequeños una
acusación parecida a la que enfrenta
alphabet que es la matriz de google y lo
que buscan es que la obliguen a vender
sus más preciados servicios escuchemos
ya que durante casi una década facebook
ha utilizado su dominio y poder
monopolístico para aplastar a sus
rivales más pequeños y acabar con la
competencia todo a expensas de los
usuarios cotidianos
facebook utiliza grandes cantidades de
dinero para así derribar más pequeños y
rivales potenciales antes de que
prendiera namigata sus dominios los dos
ejemplos más evidentes de este esquema
ilegal son instagram en whatsapp
skinwear instagram en whatsapp raúl
recordemos que en 2012 la empresa de
mark zuckerberg pagó 2 mil millones de
dólares por esta gran y dos años después
18 veces más por whatsapp dueña de todas
las comunicaciones daniel indicadores la
bolsa de nueva york él se tiñó de rojo
hoy después del optimismo de toda esta
semana por el inicio de la vacunación
contra el cob y de 19 en europa todos
pendientes de la reunión del banco
central del jueves y londres se mantiene
al alza esperando el presi t y en
américa latina se puede hablar de un
desplome en argentina después de los
festivos de lunes y martes que nos trae
hoy como cifra el día 678.000
y fue lo que en impuestos atrasados pagó
el rey emérito de españa a juan carlos
primero acusado de corrupción con esto
queda paz y salvo con hacienda y se
evita líos judiciales que podría
causarle esta adepta daniela como
siempre un placer conversar con usted
sobre temas de economía buena noche
ausàs amén que tengan una buena noche
continua con nosotros acá en france 24
[Música]